hey guys how's it going I got some
important stuff that I would like to
talk to you about um I didn't get a vlog
out last week because I just got back
from a trip to New York where I was
visiting jontron and that was a ton of
fun but it took up a lot of time and
then I was playing catch-up all last
week and I had to fly out for a day trip
to Cincinnati for my best friend Bob's
bachelor party he's getting married in
two weeks and it was a lot of fun but I
missed out on a lot of sleepin and
something really important happened last
weekend there was this communication
with my audience that happened on
Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr and some
of you may have missed out on it but I
basically wanted to get your guys's
opinion on the state of the channel and
how you thought I was doing because I
really do care about what you think this
is as much your channel as it is mine
and I got a lot of very interesting
feedback about how the channel is going
the direction it's going what kind of
content you'd like to see and all that
was addressed and all that we talked
about in great length and I responded to
a great many people but it also made me
remember a lot of very important things
about what this channel is and it's not
that I've forgotten entirely about what
it is it's just that there hasn't been
an open dialogue between us for pointing
you guys in the right direction no going
back to Cincinnati was actually very
interesting because I was staying at my
mom's house and that's where the last
charity livestream was and where most of
the charity livestreams that we've done
in the past were and it was very good to
see that because charity has always been
an extremely important part of me or my
life and what this channel is all about
and from the get-go and you can see this
way back in one of the first vlogs I
ever did after I came back from
comic-con I wanted to set this channel
apart from others because I don't just
want this to be a community that cares
about the games that I play or how I
play them or what I'm doing in terms of
the entertainment that I do I want to
build this community and I want to give
you guys free entertainment don't get me
wrong I want you guys to have fun while
you here but the main reason why I need
to be responsible about this huge
community that we have
is that you guys have so much power to
change the world
2.5 million people is an enormous number
in any respect that's bigger than many
countries it's bigger than almost every
city if you put 2.5 million people in
one place and unite them towards a
common goal they can do anything and
that's what we need to do and that's
what I've been lacking because ever
since I came to LA I have been extremely
busy and I'm not saying that as an
excuse it's just because I'm a one-man
operation I I added my own videos I
record everything I do my own thumbnails
I do all of the logistics and all the
communications and when you have as many
people as I do and you're trying to stay
rooted it's so difficult to do but
that's no excuse for me I've just been
saying that I'm busy and I've been
dropping the ball in other departments
now I've been helping other people with
charity livestreams while I'm here but
since I got here we haven't done our own
charity livestream which is what this
channel is all about I mean aside from
the games yes we play games yes we have
fun but also we are responsible because
of what we can do and what you guys can
do because I've never stopped believing
in you guys I've never stopped
understanding just how powerful we can
be when we unite towards a goal
the last charity livestream we did and I
forget how many subscribers we had we
raised $80,000 for child's play that is
an incredible number that's huge that's
beyond everything I could have hoped for
and now that we're still growing we're
still growing incredibly fast we were on
the channels just exploding we get so
many views and so many people love what
I do that I need to make sure that's
pointed in the right direction because
you guys are the most amazing thing
that's ever happened to me and if I
don't do this responsibly because I
believe in you and I know that you're
good people and I know that together we
can do great things but if we don't do
it if we don't take the time out of our
day to do it then all that is wasting
and all that's lost so I'm gonna say
this right now I'm gonna get back into
doing monthly charity livestreams no
matter what
no matter what there's always going to
be a charity effort every month no
matter how much time I have left I'm
going to dedicate that to doing at least
one charity livestream a month because
that was my original promise and there's
no excuse for not doing unless there
like every single weekend I'm flying out
somewhere which has happened over the
past few months there have been
weekend's where I'm just I'm flying from
here they're all over the place but even
if that is the case I will have
something set up so that we can always
dedicate ourselves to bettering the
world so the next charity livestream is
going to be July 12th I believe is the
next open weekend that I have in the
future so please mark your calendars for
July 12th if that changes at any time I
will let you know in advance but I'm
going to dedicate myself to hitting that
target I don't know what charity we're
going to be doing and I don't know what
effort we're gonna be doing it through
but we are going to be having a 12 hour
livestream on July 12th so that you and
I can get together and really try to
better the world because you guys have
so much power and I thank you guys for
watching my videos and I thank you guys
for being here for me and this community
that we have is just so incredible I've
always been so proud of what you guys
have done compared to many of the
communities on YouTube even at our worst
we are far and away better than some of
the most vitriolic communities out there
on YouTube and that's because you are
all good people and I believe in what
you do and I want you guys to be able to
succeed and be proud and have your
dreams come true and I can't connect on
a personal level to make sure that
happens but I can make sure that we all
together unite towards something good
and that's something that I'm never ever
going to forget no matter how big this
channel grows no matter how many people
and even though I may be a one-man
operation now if it takes the point
where I need to hire employees to help
me communicate with you guys to dedicate
ourselves and grow bigger and actually
like offset the load of work from me to
other people and make sure that we stay
grounded in what we do maybe even the
future like I have a dream to create a
markiplier charity foundation that is
just dedicated as a nonprofit to benefit
the world I want to do that someday and
I know that you guys have given me the
opportunities so just understand that
together we have so much power and even
you alone even one person out there one
subscriber can change the world so thank
you all so much for watching thank you
all so much for believing me and thank
you for joining me for charity
livestreams in the future and for the
next one on July 12th don't forget it
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye